tu crois que c'est la première fois
qu'on menace avec un flingue
tu vas mettre en retard et je déteste
être
regarde mademoiselle inconnu cherche
encore adjoindre qui fait penser que
inconnue est une demoiselle
j'imagine c'est sa balle
où sont les colis
c'est quoi ça peut y aller maintenant
sortez de la voiture toutes les trois
tout de suite personne ne sort de la
voiture maintenant foule accrochez vos
ceintures
peut-être fournis ou encore à faire
ensemble essayons de garder la tête
froide
la mediterranean banque qui a déjà été
cambriolé mais jamais comme ça les
chauffeurs c'est lui le transporteur
balcère pire vous avez besoin d'être bon
qui êtes vous toi tes amis m'avaient
pris quelque chose et moi je t'ai pris
quelque chose tu as 12 heures pour
trouver ton père avant que si on en est
là c'est à cause de toi alors on va voir
karasin être qu'on a le choix
pas vrai
il arrive
on va avoir besoin de renforts
oh
qu'est ce qui vous a pris autant de
temps
j'ai dû coucher deux ou trois bd